you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with author and journalist Christina
Patterson and the writer Benedict Spence
so let us see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the Sunday
Express leads on the home secretary's
new migrant policy the headline first
Rwanda Asylum flights this summer
the same story is on the front of the
mail on Sunday Zoella I'll send boat
migrants to Rwanda by Summer
and again this covers the front of the
Sunday Telegraph as they detail that
Zoella bravaman's deal aims to shut
loopholes that block removals
call this Justice reads the front of the
Sunday people as they look at prison
overcrowding
John Lewis eyes biggest shake-up in its
150 years raised the front of the Sunday
Times as the company looks at diluting
its partnership structure
Gary lineker's return to the BBC covers
the front of the Sunday Mirror alongside
the headline Britain should be proud of
lineker
and at the front of the Daily Star on
Sunday looks at one football Legend's
recent weight loss
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by author and
journalist Christina Patterson and the
writer Benedict Spence good evening to
both of you welcome Let's uh start by
having a look at the front of the
express and their headline is we just
ran through their first Rwanda Asylum
flights this summer and this is the
promise of Home Secretary Suella
bravaman following her visit to Rwanda
Christina
yes well this is one step nearer to
swella bravaman's I have a dream Martin
Luther King
um aspiration which is in her case uh
that she should be deporting migrants
desperate people to Rwanda and this
seems to be her top priority in life
she's Rishi sunak has vowed to stop the
votes which was probably in political
terms an extremely unwise promise to
make because the likelihood of bringing
the votes to crossing the channel to
zero is also pretty much zero but um
swella Bradman has apparently agreed
with the Rwandan government that they
have the ability to take thousands of
people she's desperately trying to uh
well she claims she has closed the
loophole in the law that was left open
from before when it was just going to be
Asylum Seekers now it's anybody Crossing
into the UK illegally according to this
new definition of illegal in the new
migration Bill illegal migration Bill
the trouble with all of this I mean I'm
in favor of stopping the boats it's it's
a terrible source of uh it basically
it's delegating uh Refugee policy to
criminals and that clearly has to be a
bad thing but the problem in deeming all
people coming into the country on the
boats as illegal is the fact that we
don't have legal Roots currently for
refugees and that seems to me to be
breaking the refugee convention and not
just to me I mean we will see there are
several stages of testing to go through
so Ella bravaman says that the high
court gave the go-ahead to her plan now
it's being contested we'll see where it
leads but I I have to say I don't think
this is a very proud moment for the UK
um Benedict the Home Secretary saying
that she's confident that legal
loopholes will be sealed off bringing a
halt to endless courtroom battles over
deportation orders she's uh very very
confident that this will will go through
her and so confident that she predicting
the the first flights by Summer
well we can only wait and see at the
previous Home Secretary was confident
that the ruhuru under plan worked as
well and of course it didn't uh take off
so to speak
um yeah the problem really I think is
that as Christina says the the
government has sort of uh nailed its
colors to the Mast on this it said that
they are going to stop the Small Boat
Crossings again as Christina points out
it's you know what actually is at stake
here is criminality it's criminal gangs
uh that will continue to you know to run
these routes for as long as they are at
large basically you know they you know
take the actual migrants out of the
equation for as long as there are
um yeah criminals prepared to smuggle
people Goods whatever it is across the
channel and it's profitable they'll
continue to do that uh that to me seems
an issue of the Criminal Justice System
of policing also potentially of policing
in France given that you know obviously
this falls under their Remus as well but
having made a bit of a rod for their own
back if they don't stop you know the
very visible sight of people coming
across the channel in these dinghies and
it's going to be kind of hard to hard to
hide if they do fail to do this then
that will be chalked up as a defeat that
will be choked up as a failure by the
government the other thing you know that
needs to be born in mind is you know the
policy broadly is is is quite popular
amongst those who have heard of it uh
because I think everybody agrees you
don't want people coming uh via the
channel it's very dangerous Crossing
everybody knows this and it puts money
into the hands of organized criminals uh
but the the what this doesn't
necessarily talk about is putting it in
the broader context of immigration in
general what you notice is actually you
know the 45 000 people that came last
year via the channel is I think about it
was about 10 of the total number of
people who actually came to the UK in
general and you notice that the
government isn't talking about that
they're not sort of trying to you know
bat back the accusations that they're
being unfriendly by saying oh well
actually the UK lets in you know a
record number of people last year
because actually that's not really very
popular amongst a lot of the tourist
called voters so you're in a situation
where the the the economy is in the dull
yeah the Jerry hunt clearly feels uh
that um migration is part of the
solution to that and so wants to
encourage it that doesn't go down very
well with the core voters so they have
to focus in laser-like on this one issue
which if you get wrong well that's a
that's a kick in the teeth with only a
few months realistically a year and a
bit until the next general election
and Christina another Point mentioned by
the Home Secretary on her two-day visit
to Kigali um she's expressing her
determination to move quickly with the
deportation flights and she's also
indicated that the UK could be prepared
to leave the European convention on
human rights if European judges block
the legislation
yes I think I mean one has the
impression she's almost relishing the
opportunity she's kind of in the um
Boris Johnson mold of government which
is you know stick it stick it to Jerry
Johnny Foreigner and let's show them
who's in charge and there seems to be a
kind of a general sense amongst a
certain rump of the Tory party possibly
the majority at the moment that this is
part of our post-brexit identity that we
are kind of buccaneering and independent
and nobody tells us what to do actually
breaking international law is never or
withdrawing from legal treaties that
you've been uh part of for many many
years isn't a good look and it's
particularly not a good look when you
have been predicted to be the only
Western economy that's likely to
um if not go into recession then not
grow next in the next financial year I
think Russia is currently predicted to
do better than us which is you know not
great given that we are the sixth
biggest economy in the world we were by
the way the fifth biggest until all of
this brexit nonsense
um struck so I mean whether whether
we'll do that I don't know but certainly
you know we thank goodness Rishi sunak
has seems to have
um seen the light in relation to the
Northern Ireland protocol because again
the jumps the knights were planning to
be all buccaneering and uh be ready to
break international law on that and
people don't trust you when you break
law when you withdraw from agreements
when it suits you when you do that on a
whim it doesn't build International
trust it certainly doesn't help in
building your soft power and it doesn't
help in building trading relationships
either so I really hope we don't just uh
to talk about uh legality
um again also in the Sunday Telegraph
the Home Secretary is quoted as saying
I'm confident the Rwanda partnership was
authoritatively upheld by the high court
in a very extensive judgment a very
rigorous analysis by senior judge is so
again the the Home Secretary confirming
that she's confident in the legality of
what they're trying to do there Benedict
yes and I mean this is of course the
very difficult situation that the
government finds itself in is that you
know you can you can be a party to
International treaties you can be party
to international law you can decide to
withdraw from these things and you can
sort of you can take the consequences of
that the problem is of course being the
you know the the party of brexit as as
the conservatives now are they need to
be seen to be taking back control not
simply talking about it because that way
they will be accused of effectively
being brexit betrayers I don't
necessarily think withdrawing from
International treaties changing
International treaties you know not
allowing the land to just be permanently
settled I don't think it's necessarily A
Bad Thing provided you have an
alternative plan that everybody else is
prepared to at least listen to and I
think part of the problem is when you
simply say to certain members of the
press oh we're just going to leave the
echr uh there isn't a plan for what
comes afterwards we're just going to
leave then that's going to solve the
issue I think a lot of people do just
kind of look at you and go well this
does seem a bit sort of you know
piecemeal it's not the most balanced
approach
um yeah obviously obviously this
government is able to negotiate some
agreements because we've managed to get
one with with Rwanda which is you know a
good start but perhaps not the place
where you'd want to start
um but nonetheless you know it is it's a
little bit shaky although I would say
also there is a lot of chicanery that
goes around with just about every
European country these days when it
comes to the thorny issue of migration
Italy is currently making it very
difficult for uh migrant boats to land
it's making incredibly difficult for
ngos uh Denmark and the other Nordic
countries are doing what they can to try
to deport people or be it they're doing
that whilst also not recognizing the
governments of the countries that they
want to send people back to so it is a
it's a thorny issue that a lot of
countries are are not really grappling
with quite so well but certainly we've
managed to make it particularly
difficult for ourselves I think it's
fair to say bend it let's let's move on
we spent quite a lot of time on on that
story although it's it's given a lot of
coverage in the papers and but also on
the telegrapher another story on the
front page Boris Johnson is preparing to
unveil uh bombshell evidence that he
believes will exonerate him over
partygate this is uh coming from allies
of his Christina
yes well it looks as though uh taxpayers
money which has been spent on defending
him in this case is going to at vast
expense it has to be said is going to
lead to uh if nothing else some quite
compelling TV this week
um Lord Panic who is representing Boris
Johnson he won't be speaking for him but
he will be present with him at the
committee this week and will be able to
advise him by writing little notes some
pieces of paper has apparently helped to
compile a dossier that allies
um of of Johnson claim will exonerate
him from misleading Parliament I have to
say I mean
we've already seen the evidence from the
committee and some of that has certainly
seemed pretty damning it's talked about
it's quoted people talking about uh
there being a piss up at Downing Street
and PR press people saying hard to know
you know why it wasn't frankly and um
and you know various people sort of on
WhatsApp messages strongly implying that
there was lots of stuff going on that
Boris Johnson certainly did know about
um and they were trying to come up with
ways to phrase this that would get him
off the hook
I think the key argument and obviously
obviously we haven't seen what will
happen this week but the key argument
seems to be that the advice that Boris
Johnson has from civil servants was that
it wasn't breaking the rules since
everybody in the country could see that
it was breaking the rules that a lot of
what went on at down the street was
breaking the rules the police determined
it was breaking the rules there was a
record number of people who were fined
for breaking the rules which was by the
way breaking the law not just the rules
it seems almost unimaginable that the
person who created that law and those
rules was unaware that he and his
colleagues were breaking it but that
seems to be the argument and we'll see
what happens this week Benedict we read
that what's being called the bombshell
defense dossier that it does actually
contain new evidence that will help Mr
Johnson's case
yes and again we wait to see what that
is I mean I I personally happen to be
entirely convinced of the view that
Boris Johnson might not have been aware
of his own laws that he'd passed and
therefore wasn't aware that he was
breaking them but that doesn't mean that
he didn't then mislead Parliament all
India that he didn't break them in the
first place and I think really
every sort of story that creeps up about
Boris Johnson to me it just sort of
strikes me as a little bit more
desperate a little bit more clawing you
know it was only a couple of months ago
that people were talking about a
sensational comeback and whether or not
he'd got the numbers to go for him and
now I just feel that the the the
enthusiasm and the tide is sort of
ebbing away from him because let's be
honest I think whatever the findings are
he's pretty damned I think in the court
of public opinion and I think that all
of this just reminds us of this Hail
Mary election victory that Boris Johnson
managed to get a few years ago and quite
how badly he has managed to squander an
an almost insurmountable position based
entirely off his own his own decisions
in his own flat in his own office based
around rules that he brought in that so
many other people abided by the you know
controlled so many other people's lives
and ultimately apparently either he did
a deliberately or just didn't give them
a second thought I think I can predict
that many people be glued to the commons
privileges committee on Wednesday when
he gives evidence for the moment
Christina and Benedict thank you we are
going to take a break coming up we'll be
taking a look at some more stories on
the front of tomorrow's newspapers
including this on the front of the
Sunday Times it's headline damage to
women's trust in police will last
Generations Chief Constable says stay
with us for more on that story and
others
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Christina
Patterson and Benedict spent let's have
a look at the front of the times and
this story about the fact that women's
trust in the the police has been damaged
and will last for Generations according
to a senior female Chief Constable Lucy
Dorsey she's head of the British
transport police Christina
yes well Lucy Dorsey has said that she
thinks um the damaged women's trust in
police for last generations and
and it's hard to disagree with that I I
would be surprised I think probably
every woman in the country has felt that
whatever trust they had in the police
severely undermined by the absolute
Horrors first of the ways uh Wayne
cousins murder of Sarah everard but also
of what through what has emerged
subsequently in WhatsApp groups just
full of misogyny uh sexism
racism
hate basically and violence and that has
been and then there's been an endless
trickle of reports about
um allegations of sexual violence by
police serving police officers very few
of whom have lost their jobs or been
prosecuted so I think this is in a way
just a statement of the obvious and this
week baroness Casey who never pulls her
punches has um written a 300 page report
which will be published which I gather
will be extremely Downing of the police
now I think we all knew it would be
because of what's emerged so far but it
is really really worrying when the
people who are meant to
prosecute criminals keep us safe
can no longer be trusted obviously this
doesn't apply to the vast majority of
police but it clearly does apply to a
significant swathe of them and that is
is a dreadful situation and I imagine
it's going to take quite a while to sort
out yes but I mean Benedict how do does
the force turn this around
well I mean this is the thing actually I
think we have a tendency in this country
to be quite sort of declinist and you
know when you read the headline the
women will not be able to trust the
police for a very long time for
Generations potentially the response has
to be from the police to say well we're
not going to allow that to be the case
and it's actually really easy to turn
that round it is to expel those members
of your ranks who are behaving in that
sort of uh behavior and prosecute those
who have broken the law and you need to
investigate very very thoroughly uh your
own ranks and then on top of that do
your jobs uphold the law investigate
things you know actually uh turn up to
incidences where people are claiming
they have been assaulted or are being
mistreated in some way actually this is
entirely within the police's power to
combat you know they are the ultimate
yeah they are the front line the
Arbiters of the law and Authority in
this country so actually in many ways
they have a far better opportunity to
fix the reputational damage that they've
done to themselves than most other
professions do this will require uh
positivity in a proactive sense it will
require them looking at what has gone
wrong and working to fix those those
issues this can be done I don't think it
has to be the case uh that that women or
any other group need fear or mistrust
the police it just requires some willing
that will come from politicians giving
them the resources as much as the force
but it can be done okay very positive um
Outlook from you there Benedict let's um
we've got a short amount of time have a
look at this Sunday Telegraph in this
story Christina that uh Trump Donald
Trump is predicting that he will be
arrested on Tuesday I think he's saying
and he's calling on his supporters to
take to the streets yet again
yes but I think if there's anyone in the
world who can't really be trusted near
women
um I think Donald Trump probably
features quite prominently
um he also I mean it's so ironic that
his uh social media uh platform is
called Truth social because I don't
think he's uh world famous for his
truth-telling either yes he's announced
that he's likely to be arrested this
week in relation to these Stormy Daniels
um a case which is where there were
allegations that he basically paid her
off
um this is a prostitute
um a porn star sorry who he uh is
alleged to have had a relationship with
and then paid off and of course he
denies all allegations because he always
does but the really significant thing
well there are two really significant
things one is that he's the possibility
that he's arrested if so he would become
only the second former president of the
US to be arrested but the other is that
even after the horrors of January the
6th 2021 when people died as a result of
his essentially again people aren't
Britain
um he is one egging people on to protest